et bien effectivement s'invente à la
mobilisation est déjà au rendez vous ici
pas loin du jardin du luxembourg un
cortège qui vient de s'élancer pour
rejoindre le ministère de l'éducation
voilà le parcours de cette manifestation
objectif vous l'avez dit elle c'est de
réclamer une revalorisation salariale
mais aussi un recrutement massif afin de
faire face à la crise sanitaire puisque
les professeurs les enseignants elles
sont en première ligne dans ce contexte
sanitaire à ces attaques particulier je
me trouve actuellement avec brice castel
qui est assistant social et membre du
syndicat fsu
fabrice bonjour pourquoi c'est important
d'être là pour vous cet après midi c'est
important parce qu on est dans une
situation qui est dramatique au niveau
l'éducation nationale on voit bien que
la crise sanitaire a amplifié les jalles
la crise sociale qui était présente
auparavant et on se retrouve dans une
situation où on a un gouvernement qui
est sourd aux demandes des personnels
qui va plus loin dans sa casse du
service public d'éducation
et aujourd'hui c'est pas possible de
continuer comme ça on est si proche de
l'explosion parfum de la situation
sociale des élèves est dramatique et il
ya toujours aucun moyen de développer
pour y faire face alors jean michel
bancaire organise le grenelle de
l'éducation jugé comme inacceptable pour
la plupart des syndicats c'est votre
avis également 8 août a fait le grenelle
d'éducation très âgées avant même sa
mise en oeuvre que ce serait une
opération d'abord de communication au
service de la politique menée de
destruction du service public
d'éducation et
les conclusions annoncées aujourd'hui le
démontre bien
c'est uniquement une opération qui sert
à dire on continue la casse du service
public d'éducation
merci beaucoup bruit d'avoir répondu à
nos questions voilà vous l'aurez compris
la colère est de mise pour tous les
enseignants les assistant social mais
également des étudiants qui sont
présents parmi le cortège un important
dispositif de sécurité a été mis en
place pour encadrer cette manifestation
qui je vous le disais se terminera
devant le ministère de l'éducation